y evitar que irán desarrolle armas
nucleares es una meta común para eeuu e
israel así se desprende de las
declaraciones de antony blinken en el
inicio de su gira de dos días por israel
y el territorio palestino de cisjordania
donde difieren estos dos grandes aliados
es en las formas mientras el secretario
de estado defendió el acuerdo nuclear
como la mejor solución el gobierno
israelí reiteró su rechazo al pacto
además el primer ministro israelí
naftalí bennett él le pidió a blinken
que eeuu no retire a la guardia
revolucionaria iraní de su lista de
organizaciones terroristas una de las
exigencias de teherán para volver a
cumplir el acuerdo por supuesto la
ofensiva rusa en ucrania ocupa buena
parte de la agenda tras el duro discurso
de joe biden en polonia el jefe de la
diplomacia estadounidense aclaró que
eeuu no tiene una estrategia para un
cambio de régimen en rusia y respaldó la
postura de israel cuya ambigüedad ha
sido criticada dijo que washington
observa de cerca los esfuerzos de
mediación de benet por otro lado antes
de reunirse en ramala con el presidente
de la autoridad palestina mahmud abbas
blinken remarcó que washington busca
mejores condiciones de vida para los
palestinos y pidió que todas las partes
se garanticen la paz en abril en el que
coincidirán el ramadán la pascua
cristiana y el pesaje judío sin embargo
palestina no ocupa un lugar central en
la gira del secretario de estado quien
participa de una inédita cumbre con los
cancilleres de israel egipto marruecos
emiratos árabes unidos y bahrein en el
desierto de néguev una espaldarazo de
los acuerdos que habrán firmado bajo la
administración trump que permitieron la
normalización de relaciones entre las
eliminaciones árabes pero un revés para
la dirigencia palestina que se ve aún
más aislada en la región al respecto del
ministerio de exteriores palestino acusó
a israel de utilizar la reunión como una
forma de invisibilizar la causa
palestina y profundizar su política de
ocupación